am going to be working on a little bit
of just optimization on this
here first things first let's move this
this do this
HC
puffer
here is it not installed an editable mod
or something
oh that's how long it takes to load the
bloody data
that's like nothing
right that's four
anything I think we're going to for
testing we're going to
okay good synced up there
so yeah all I have to do at this point
is figure out how to optimize this EMP a
bit got some information on on this we
should be
good
um memory ain't coming from buffers
oh hey there you are
K so actually I can tell you this right
now then because this is this is just a
very very useful technique um so what I
tend to find is like when you're taught
to program in and I don't I don't know
if I think it's just cuz you started
from the original like phc code I don't
think it's cuz like you intentionally
like you know restructured the thing
that I did but um they teach you this
thing when you taught to program where
it's like keep your method short
um literally the most useful technique I
have for cleaning up research code bases
is to just unroll all of the methods
everywhere where it doesn't require
duplicating code just unroll all the
methods because what you find is like
stuff is declared several times stuff is
redundant to give you an idea I did this
on the carbs database yesterday and I
cut out 600 lines of code just by doing
that um you can put some of the methods
back after you've done that after you've
cleaned stuff up if you want but uh
generally there
are two things I like two ways I decide
to like put stuff into a function uh the
first is if I'm going to have to copy
paste code otherwise like a big block of
code I'll put it in a separate function
uh and the second one is if stuff gets
nested super deep but if like I have
like a 300 line in it and it's just like
you big block of stuff that's like not
deeply nested pretty clean to follow
I'll just block it with comments and
I'll just put it all in the one method
and then you can actually see what
everything's doing and it's easier to
dup
stuff so that was the one thing that was
the one comment I had on that I'm going
to work right now on figuring
out where perf is
leaking yeah but I just wanted to make
sure you got that that uh trick because
it is very useful
first thing I want to try is loading all
the Bots into one
environment I think I saw the Bots are
now being loaded into separate MS
so there's a small perf boost but I'm
also wondering about
memory I'm wondering if there's a memory
impact difference
okay so this is just generating data and
we're already up to 6
Gigabytes this isn't even running the
M that part I wanted to go later but
cool yeah yeah yeah so that's uh I'm
going to work on this m stuff but yeah
unrolling code like that is it's a very
very powerful technique because like you
have to kind realize and assume that
when you're looking at an academic code
base or a researcher code base
scientists just suck at writing code and
they overly abstract everything so like
if you unroll all the methods it becomes
very clear that the thing that they did
doesn't make any sense and you can start
cutting
stuff that's typically the reason for
it like the carbs repo is actually
completely broken
um now I can realize that now that I did
that I actually wasn't looking at the
damn I forgot to look at the the memory
increase actually hold on no before we
do this there's
something something deeply
screwy yeah they The Sweep stuff is
going to take me a little longer but
it's very
promising something else I wanted to do
which is
where you have reset
here and then reset loads the data
right but
hold on need an extra terminal so I can
watch memory usage and just put this up
on this
side okay so we have
okay 2.9
GB seems to be what I'm actually
using I don't actually know there's this
one weird process on here I don't know
what I'm using it for it's probably just
xor or something so 3
gigs and then loading
this we're at 6 gigs right
now from
this okay and if I do load
motion good the motion loading isn't
taking more
memory so I mean 3 GB of memory is not
terrible um you said 20 gigs of vram for
2048 that's pretty rough we'll have to
look if figure that out if that's the
case
ideally as well we should just
pre-process all of it and then dump it
to file so we don't have to deal with
that yeah
exactly so I'm only seeing three
caused I don't actually know how much
SPS we get above 2048 though it's not
going to be permanently linear
so here we're going to allocate buffers
and we're at 6.8
right and because most of those are cop
are not
all and now I'm going to watch the perf
test
eight are you sure it uses 20
gigs I only see uh it only goes up to
eight for me K goes from 3 to eight five
gigs clear will be clear when I have
training Loop unrolled yeah just like
that's what I suggest with the academic
code you literally just anytime you
don't have to actually copy the code
twice or more um by unrolling it just
unroll it so like any function that's
called once basically you just
unroll that was 2048 so I don't see
where you're getting 20 gigs usage were
you getting 20 gigs usage on a training
test by any chance or were you getting
it just from this perf test I'm not
seeing your 20
that means you're using 12 gigs of
training and you're probably we're
probably going to want a CPU
offload don't worry about that the m is
not
ridiculously bad in this department but
I don't know if you've tested it with um
with
more we really should attach the um the
data as well so that uh it's not this
slow let me see
your you just linked me that
um are you missing the uh the usual
stuff that puffer
logs like the dashboard and
stuff cuz the dashboard should be
logging M time um train time it should
be logging all those things
that's not oh this is not from puffer I
see is this not from clean puff
puffero okay well I'm not going to be
able to tell very much from this
unfortunately on its own
RL games yeah okay unfortunately though
you're not going to get any more um
SPS you're capped at
2048 the only thing that it could do is
it could potentially make training a
little bit faster but I think that
usually 2048 to
4096 um on the slightly larger Nets were
likely to be using probably you won't
see much of a
difference so the only thing we can
really do here here is look for other
optimizations how did you disable self
Collision uh without putting all the
bots in the same
n actually that's kind of
suspicious you cuz you saw I saw you
have the flag for
it just the memory oh yeah
well they're probably just like I can
see the environment is not taking that
so that just must be the buffers
right oh also layer Norm can sometimes
I think glorm sometimes does weird stuff
maybe not in the memory maybe it's just
though let's see if I instantly see
speed up
okay you do instantly see some speed
up not what I was
expecting I probably have to run the
full
test it's 40K
before this should be very noticeable
though this should
be more than double I believe
and if it isn't then I'll be suspicious
as to how this is being
disabled Collision off yeah but I put
them into the same
M actually I think I tested both ways to
be fair and I don't think there was a
difference other than like
4% cuz see Isaac Jim will actually just
put them them all into the same end for
you but you have to pay the little
conversion
price this is weird that you're only
getting an extra um 50% this is the same
model and everything isn't
it the same
humanoid the same humanoid
well I saw that there were some changes
to some of these parameters as well
weren't
same this Flex thing is gone I don't
know if this was
important Max GPU contact
pairs these are the
same I don't know if that changes
anything we can play with it
don't need Flex
gotcha some friction coefficients and
stuff changed as
well I
noticed did you get this uh where is it
the angular damping or
whatever I think I told you there was
some damping that was
one so these were the ones that were
required to prevent the bot from like
flying off into
then I know if you don't have those it
will fly off into space
okay if you've tested that then that's
[Music]
fine looking for anything else that
could be different
the academic repos they just chip down
their perf they chip their per down they
chip it down and then there's nothing
okay
so three time
so this thing is not doing anything this
is
free it's mostly in the M step itself
but there is a substantial overhead to
this post step
would this account for
it I don't think this would quite
account for it cuz we had
10 130k before so I think that the base
Sim itself is slow lower as
well is there anything changed to the
configuration of the Sim or the bot
itself that would slow it
down versus my
130 CU I do see that there's a bit of
overhead added by this Ops computation
and stuff which is a little weird but
well there's no reason not to put them
all in the same
M pretty sure
is this code right
here create Sim upper lower
[Music]
CL and then you need do you have num
actors
everything this looks like it's only
filtering specific
user aggregate size exceeded
I think we got that before I think
that's
fine oh but the thing is that you have
to put them
um you need to spread the uh the agents
out if you do
yeah so what's happening here is that
there
are there are too many uh BFF they're
all stacked on top of each
other and this is why the SPs sucks
you want to do is manually spread them
out a little bit
uh seg fful if we do not randomize the
position that's moderately
though that's a very weird seful T have
I don't trust that but whatever
motion key is converted from the
original
thises pause get used it does right
start pose
these things like run a super far
distance or
something it
shouldn't and that still wouldn't cause
this because then they would yeah they
shouldn't cause
this this worked when I I had this in
the repo so what happened
here I spread them out and they still uh
still don't work
somehow
yeah so uh something is wrong with the
scene because when I set this up this
didn't
happen me
see build and
Enid let me just try real quick what
happens if I hard code
01 this
okay it could possibly be these filter
RS yeah cuz you're overriding the filter
okay
disable S
we're going to get this bloody thing
back to
130 130 FPS thank you very mucher
and let's just go look at our Sim and
see where it's different I
props handles
it's got a unique ID
yeah
wait want from oril X
zyx is it
zyx no cuz I
have start pose it's going to be a
transform
backwards I guess the most productive
thing is to try to just pull up the
renderer on this
right I don't know what the heck is
wrong with
it
there is our
renderer see a renderer
trying to remember if there was anything
special that needed to be done to get
this thing to show
up didn't think
render so wait does do this thing need
to
have how does this thing not
error when I do this
so as I
expected the uh the position arcs don't
seem to be taking
here
where the heck is spacing and where is
it getting
[Music]
overridden spacing this five
hey Spencer um working on Isaac Jim
stuff at the moment that we did make
some progress on sweeps as well
stupid hi again back second stream
yep always working on stuff that's how
it goes
on I think this a literally order of
operations that's funny
no no it is not
okay so this is what your nested methods
will do I had to go down four layers to
find this
right I actually have no idea how the
how that
worked
still hang
on something is getting zeroed
here this is bad because it means that
you're not resetting correctly either
okay so you set velocity and angular
velocity to
meanwhile I can definitely tell you this
is not resetting
correctly oh okay um I got to go take a
call couple calls actually um I will try
to be back later though uh K this is not
resetting correctly if you're still
around I'm going to try to find it but
uh it's when you set the initial pause
it doesn't get set correctly so I
suspect that's probably causing other
issues